es ist ja so dass die hoffnung zuletzt
stirbt aber ich gehe wirklich davon aus
dass dieses oktoberfest nicht
stattfinden wird
was hat das für auswirkungen auf sie auf
ihren betriebe was bedeutet dass
finanziell und organisatorisch
es ist so dass natürlich sicherlich für
uns wir bereiten uns das ganze jahr über
vorhaben da einige mitarbeiter die das
ganze jahr oktoberfest machen
auf der anderen seite ist wenn der
absage jetzt in den nächsten wochen
kommt bedeutet es natürlich dass der
ganze aufbau noch nicht begonnen hat und
alles drum noch nicht stattgefunden hat
es ist sicherlich eine möglichkeit hier
nochmal im wenn man den richtigen
zeitpunkt wählt das wirtschaftlich
einigermaßen gut über die runden zu
kommen zu bekommen das ist natürlich in
meinem betrieb so aber ich denke
natürlich auch ganz schwer an die vielen
kollegen die da sind und es sind ja
nicht nur wir das sind auch schausteller
das sind auch ganz kleine betriebe ob
das ein eisstand ist ob das eine brezel
brauch ist und natürlich wirtschaftlich
sicherlich nicht ganz großes problem und
auch für die ganze stadt münchen das
oktoberfest ist nicht nur ein fest dass
auf der theresienwiese stattfindet
sondern erhängen hotels dran der
gastronomie in der stadt dran
viele viele einzelhandel leben die
menschen kaufen sich betrachten und all
diese punkte also es ist schon ein
erhebliches problem für die wirtschaft
besonders in münchen also für sie für
die wirtschaft für münchen wer klarheit
so hörig daraus das wichtigste
eigentlich das jetzt nicht lange die
entscheidung vor sich hergeschoben wird
sondern jetzt klartext gesprochen wird
also das ist sicherlich der wichtigste
punkt aber ich habe gerade jetzt auch
der konkurrenz
habt ihr habt dazu gehört und hier kamen
auch klar die worte heraus dass das der
ministerpräsident mit dem
oberbürgermeister über das thema reden
wird und die stadt münchen ist der
veranstalter und ich bin überzeugt dass
ich dort münchen da den richtigen weg
finden wird und uns bald eine antwort
geben geben wird die immer hoffnung so
hoffnungsvoll noch sein werde aber ich
gehe auch davon aus dass das es nicht
stattfinden wird und ich persönlich aber
das ist jetzt wirklich nur um rein meine
persönliche meinung
irgendwie trotzdem wirtschaftlichen
probleme die der haus auch für uns und
für alle
den werden sie es als richtig an weil
die gesundheit muss gefördert werden und
das andere steht vor allem die
gesundheit aller menschen stehen vor
allem und das nächste ist das auch wenn
vielleicht ein zweiter welle kommen
würde und das oktoberfest dadurch mit
den leidenschaft käme oder einfach nur
in verruf käme dann wäre das ein punkt
der das oktober dem dem oktoberfest
jahrzehntelang schaden würden und auch
das muss man bedenken
großveranstaltungen bis zum 31.08 nicht
möglich ich werde die nächsten zwei
wochen mit dem oberbürgermeister von
münchen ein intensives gespräch machen
wir beide sind aber sehr skeptisch ob
auch das oktoberfest überhaupt möglich
ist und wir werden nächsten zwei wochen
entscheidung treffen
aus heutiger sicht bin ich da sehr
skeptisch kann mir das ehrlich gesagt
nicht vorstellen aber wir wollen es ein
seriöser weise entscheiden die einzige
veranstaltung die wir ab mai für möglich
halten sind gottesdienste dort für
dieses gespräche mit den kirchen statt
über kluge konzepte mit möglicherweise
mehreren gottesdienst an einem tag
freuen eine größeren kirchen um den
abstand zu zu organisieren das
hygienische anspruch aber das ist
grundsätzlich wichtig geschützte recht
religionsausübung möglich ist